Her low freak bitches.
They have to film it by 2018
you think Bert was still be fat?
100% absolutely.
You really committed to this.
Of course,
man.
He's a guy with feelings.
I know and I love him.
He's one of my best friends.
I would do anything for that guy.
If you can get inside
his head and change him.
Yeah.
Would you stop get them to stop drinking?
No.
What about after January
3rd definitely not.
No.
I want them to be happy.
The only way he'll be happy
as if he keeps drinking.
Absolutely.
Maybe with new technology,
they'll figure out a way
to fix your liver maybe,
but we'll have like a stem cell liver
cleanse and I'll just pump that shit in
there and way,
way into the bird is thin future.
Maybe I'll do something like that and
maybe Burt will have to drink more because
his liver will be so good
that the booze won't last.
Right.
So we're up in like 20 minutes
fucking partying harder.
He's a fun guy to party with.
Oh yes.
Have you ever seen him do
stand out with a shirt on?
Yes.
Back in the good times.
Um,
I saw him for a while doing it.
He used,
he used to do it.
He only started doing that,
I feel like about two years ago,
maybe three.
I feel like it's,
it's fairly recent in the time that I've
known him and seen him to stand up and
I'm,
and I think it was since then.
Have you ever seen him do
stand up with a shirt on?
No,
I haven't either.
Yeah,
it's,
um,
but it works.
It's almost like part of the persona,
you know?
Well,
it's like,
I forget when he didn't used to.
Dude.
Is he bigger than you or is it just me?
Not Man.
No,
we're about the same.
About the same size.
How does his pants stay right
above his dick like that?
That seems impossible.
It seems like there's a belt,
this belt right there.
Yeah.
But that,
that's different photo Moshe
Kasher showing his goods.
Tighty whities Moshe is a funny guy too,
man.
He's got a new show coming out on top.
On comedy central.
Yeah.
That's,
um,
it's a really cool idea.
I'm sure it will be back
to talk to very smart dude.
Yeah.
Very,
very smart.
Was that Brian Couch on his abs with Bert
Kreischer that right below that is the
MDF,
I would say to gift.
See,
I'm so sorry Brian.
But when that's a little tiny image,
it does look like Brian Keaulana.
Tell me,
does it damn look at Eddie,
Eddie shredded Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
So it was bird looks good there.
No,
that's not true at all.
Um,
Eddie is a crossfit shit.
Oh,
is he loves crossfit.
It's just got that bloated
distended thing though.
Well that's booze.
That's what I'm saying.
That's it.
There's no way he can get out of that.
I think he could.
What's he down to now?
Was he claiming?
I don't know,
cause he hasn't claimed in a minute.
Oh,
well here's a photo that
he keeps bringing it up.
Have him back when he was real
thin when he was real young,
like in college.
That's hilarious.
He's bringing that one out.
But getting back to that bro,
they were talking about um,
what's going on in the Ohio river that um,
they're,
they're putting these catfish in lakes
and they're taking them out of rivers are
putting large cat fish in
lakes but they can't survive.
They can only live in
these lakes for so long.
But everybody wants to
catch a big catfish.
So they have these commercial cat
fishing businesses where recreational
catfishing where they'll take these
people and they'll have them fishing and
these lakes and the use some sort of
chemical in the lake that forces the cat
fish to bite.
Yeah.
And this,
this chemical fish bordello yeah,
it's really gross man.
Cause the causes these legions
on the catfish is skin.
So these people catch these catfishes
and they have cat fish rather sorry.
And they have these red sores all over
their body because some chemicals have
been introduced into the water,
which I guess the irritant causes
them to like they're biting out of
frustration.
I guess maybe the unspeakable
and pursuit of the inedible.
What's is so bizarre,
like what a strange choice
that people have decided.
Let's take this animal out there.
There's one with legions on it.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
We'll see.
Another issue.
Rides on bigger calf fishes
are introduced into pay lakes.
Yeah.
So legs.
Yeah,
they have these lakes.
So I didn't even know that.
I didn't even know there was a paleo.
Like look at the all
the spots on that one.
Look at the fucking spot on that day.
And I'm,
you find what it says that chemical
is that they dumped into the water.
Just go to the Rappahannock
river in Virginia.
You'll catch a nice one.
I've got 70 pounders.
Well
in a river.
Really?
Yeah.
I mean how many of them are out?
Which,
which fish you catch is a blue.
That's a white fish.
A white cat.
Cause it's a big one by cats.
Bluecat's channel cats.
But yeah,
blues and whites are usually the biggest.
Did you apply?
Heads get really big too,
but they don't live in Virginia.
I don't think it's called juicing.
Okay.
The chemicals they put in the water make
the fish bite in the pay lake industry.
It's called juicing.
Well weird.
Look at the fucking lesions on that thing.
Scroll up a little Jamie,
back up.
Look at the poor things body.
It's just wrong.
It's bizarre.
It's not just wrong.
I tell you,
I don't really understand how that ever
got past people who are like accepting
that.
Like that's a natural one.
The one below that.
This seems totally healthy that
some got caught from a river.
So these pay lakes is a,
it's like a,
I guess it's like a private land thing.
So many owns and it just keeps dumping
these fish in there and apparently they
don't live there very long.
They all else a fishing equivalent of a,
of a,
those little teeny high fence
places you see in the east.
Go Hunt,
go hunt elk on 40 acres.
How hard was it for you to get sober?
Uh,
fear was a big motivator in that for me.
You know,
losing my family was,
that was,
that was the thing that scared me so much.
That was the bottom.
I hit that my family's going to go away
because of my behaviors that I brought
home from the road.
I got kicked out of the house by my wife.
I was living on my own somewhere in,
uh,
you know,
I did not want that.
And maybe as part of my upbringing,
you know,
uh,
my family kind of
disintegrated when I was a kid,
you know,
father left,
my mother passed away.
I live with my brother and then
Kinda just all like family,
you know,
where'd my stuff go?
Where,
where it just kind of floated away
and I do not want that happening,
you know,
no matter what's going on,
we're going to talk this
stuff out and make it work,
you know?
And my wife's of the same,
uh,
same idea,
same thought that,
you know,
her,
her family,
she was the invisible kid too,
you know,
so we relate a lot,
so there's no way we're going to let
you know any argument getting the way or
just,
you know,
we're survivors,
we're survivors and we're gonna,
we're gonna talk through
it no matter how much.
And you know,
she,
she did the right thing.
She kicked my ass,
right the hell out of the house,
you know,
and um,
that scared the shit out of me.
So,
and she said,
hey,
you're not just going to the therapist
now you're talking about this.
You got to go somewhere
and sort this shit out.
So that's what I did.
So Rehab did,
Rehab really worked for me,
telling you,
you to go for a while.
What worked for me was,
uh,
seven weeks,
someplace like basically
tearing you down to bones,
ripping your life apart.
Anything you thought about
yourself or what it was,
anything you thought you had,
your family,
your career,
your,
anything gone strip you down to just,
okay,
you're born,
here's how you were when you were born.
You were okay,
you're a good,
good person.
Let's get back to that again.
And then they slowly rebuild you.
And then I went to a,
uh,
another,
they call them aftercare places.
I went there,
uh,
to a couple of different ones and they
fined tuned stuff and get integrated back
into life.
Because when you were in
this cocoon and you're,
you're frigging raw.
I mean,
I was raw meat when I came out and you
can see it in that some kind of monster
movie.
I was pretty raw still.
I didn't know what I could or
what I should or shouldn't do,
you know.
Um,
so the,
the last place we went to was a
place that helps relationships.
So they got me and my wife
together and we'd see,
see people separately and then come
together and talk about what we did and
communication frigging
saved my life saved,
uh,
our family,
um,
and working through that stuff.
So very grateful for my wife.
She's the one that
didn't ask for this shit.
She walked through fire with me and
we walked out together stronger,
way stronger than we ever
would have been before.
And you know,
my kids know my story.
My kids know my struggles and
they respect that.
They respect me and a different way.
I don't have to tell them what to
do all the time or just be like,
I'm this,
I can say sorry.
I can tell them,
hey,
here's what happened when I did that.
And you know,
I don't need to preach to them.
They got their own stuff,
but now they,
now they goof with me.
I ruined my trust with my family and now
by some miracle they are goofing with
me.
He's like,
Dad,
shut up.
What do you get them like,
come on.
You know your overblowing
this your way out of dad.
You're taken up way too much space here.
Okay.
So they helped me and I realized
that there is help in a loving way.
[inaudible].